Josh we are talking star wars the force
awakens once again warning there are
will be spoilers in this video so if you
have not seen the movie get out we've
been thinking about the movie all
weekend and there's three things nagging
at the back of our brains so these are
questions and these are what we think
the answers could be they might not be
the first one is what is up with the map
to Luke Skywalker bb-8 gets a little
piece of a map from lure the mayor of a
town on jakku no idea how he got it it's
only part of a map the rest of it is in
our two system somehow he wakes up at
the end of the movie he is the rest of
the map and somehow they connect the
dots and they know exactly where Luke
Skywalker's that doesn't make a lot of
sense in a lot of ways because maps and
space don't exactly work like maps on
planets like a puzzle piece missing and
then there was like the dotted line to
the planet where they probably don't
really need a dotted line to a planet
could just be this planet and they go
straight there right but the question is
how did our to wake up how did he get
the map right and I believe we're
talking about the same leak which was I
think JJ confirmed this JJ was in an
interview with the Entertainment Weekly
he says that he actually got that info
r2d2 from when he accessed the Death
Star computers and a new hope Lenny like
plugged his little finger and and spun
it all around and that's and then he had
that in his backup which is how the new
order or the first order had that info
kylo Ren mentions it was ranaut backups
yeah so same source of information there
when bb-8 rolls up and pulls the cloth
off r2d2 he apparently says like hey I
have part of the map do you have the
rest of it and then r2d2 thinks about it
for a while and then at the end wakes up
and he's like yeah I do have that map
and raise being there is coincidental
people thought her maybe being daughter
of Luke kind of happened to wake up r2
he was like programmed to wake up when
she arrived yeah I felt they explained
like the whole like I think we've talked
about the gripe that you and I both have
is like how puzzle ish and visually
spoon-fed it's it's just really bizarre
so it's like oh here's the missing piece
but they say when they talk about it it
makes more sense as far as I remember
where I think Han Solo says that this is
just the beginning pieces of it like he
says we can't understand anything about
this
the my oppression the galaxy is so big
we just have a couple of systems that
are undeniable c-3po also says this
matches no known system right they could
have done the reference to that yeah the
reference is what that was right
lighting that puzzle piece yeah I think
visually it could've been cooler if it
was maybe like a couple layers or like
yeah I mean it just visually it was like
so gimmicky but and also here's what
JJ's interview also said it could it was
a map of Jedi temples and so there they
could have done it this way they could
have done they had a map of thousands of
them in what lork and bb-8 could have
had was the one that Luke was actually
at or perhaps it highlighted one that
was special because I think I heard that
this is the first one so Luke actually
went to the first Jedi Temple when she
finds him you see all those stacked
stones I thought that's how he spent his
time but that could be a very old temple
yeah and I think that's what kind of the
the Waypoint with when you look at the
whole map as a whole it's kind of like
it looked like a series of stops like he
essentially was hitting all these
temples and then the lat and that may be
the last one was was where he imagined
to be right or it could be going like
further back in time or there also is in
Star Wars like in more remote regions
and the smaller ships you need
hyperspace buoys to jump between so
maybe that was just a hyperspace route
but like with the might of the
government I'm sure they could have
figured something out like yes our
destroyers and bigger capital ships
don't need that second question we have
film there's been a lot of talk about
raised force vision when she touches
Luke's blade his and Anakin's blade uh
so there's some cool clues there a lot
of like cool little secrets that aren't
really like huge mysteries like if you
watch it a couple times you notice you
hear Yoda's voice you hear obi-wan's
voice which is and then the dirge a
confirmed that it was just a snippet
they cut out from the original trilogy
like you can you could find a moment
where obi-wan technically says rain
weather be in a sentence two more so
they just took those out which is pretty
cool actually heard the Ewan McGregor
might have recorded a line oh ok it was
even greater not baseball Guinness they
used both Wow and then she starts out in
the hallway so it's easy to think that
maybe thats Starkiller base people like
compared
to the original its cloud city 100% its
cloud city when luke and vader have
their fight and they're going out to the
turbine area in the middle so that's
really cool detail really cool but
that's not our question our question is
what happened at the Jedi Temple with
the Knights of Ren um I believe
speculation that it basically just shows
Luke Skywalker putting his hand on r2d2
giving him maybe the plans or he already
and now he already had him I guess he
was probably telling him actually now we
had that way now that that changes my
mind I thought maybe with his robot hand
he could have been giving him
information or instructions but now now
it's just really not just sentimental I
needed ashamed by SIA cuz kylo Ren just
killed all of my pupils which is
basically that's the layout right so
people people were saying that in the
dream sequence he's killing someone and
the speculation that people are claiming
is that the guy he kills was the
previous leader of knights of ren leader
or in the Knights of Ren they see the
helmet in the mask and think that he's a
member the night sauron personally I
think he's just another probably the
last one of the Jedi apprentices because
then the next shot is there in the field
the rest of the Nights around are like
cool with it i feel like if their leader
just got killed they'd be fighting and
then they're surrounded by bodies so
think about this though actually I
didn't think what this I mean it's all
speculation right but the guy he kills
is facing the wrong way like that is
like classic backstabbing shot like if
they were actually fighting like that
dude should have been facing ran but he
wasn't it was like I imagine maybe they
they just killed all these Jedi and then
ran just like the typical dark side way
kills his masters or something like that
maybe maybe that was like womens masters
something it's possible i still think
that he's Jedi because the Jedi
apprentices like the younglings they
also wore those hats yeah that's right
so I mean it could be a throwback just
because he's wearing a mask doesn't mean
he's not to run that is a good point
about him facing the other direction and
then one shot that doesn't really seem
to fit is kylo Ren panza said looks at
the camera and it makes you think he's
looking or he sees ray my theory is she
wasn't really necessarily in that scene
at all I don't think so either what I've
seen people kind of proposes that
he saved her life colorin and then maybe
even killed the rest of the night sauron
to protect himself and then hid her away
on jakku kylo did kylo did not Luke or
someone else not Luke orhan or whatever
but that implies that kylo knew she was
for sensitive because she was he never
did like he remember how surprised he
was by her if he if he personally put
her on jakku he would know who she is
that she was on jakku I guess he does
get scared when he finds out there's a
girl so he could know it could remember
I think he know of he knows of the girl
maybe I mean he knew Luke's daughter
that was very nice yeah that scene
that's interesting my problem with that
scene is I think it was supposed to be
ambiguous but the way it was shot and
edited was like you couldn't even tell
what was going on a little too much like
I wish he knew kind of if he saved her
or if he was just killing people like
knowing that would have been enough cool
that's one and then what's the what's
the last question we have here what are
they referring to by calling this movie
star wars the force awakens I think I
have two points one is that I don't
think it necessarily the force awakens
has to be one thing in the movie like
this is the new era of Jedi's coming
back again ever since Kyle Lohse
betrayal like it's finding Luke it's
everyone becoming force-sensitive this
is setting up the whole trilogy for them
to learn how to be Jedi that's what it's
kind of talking about but in the movie
kylo & smokes say they felt an awakening
right something like that right so that
obviously has to refer to something the
obvious answer is it's ray because she's
for sensitive i propose that it's
actually Finn that they feel because
when they say that the only thing that's
really happened so far in the movie it's
before she touches the lightsaber birds
before she gets mind interrogated by
kylo then meeting up there just escaped
from the Falcon exceeds in the Falcon
and they know that han Solo is with them
I think that's what that's all they know
right because he mentions like you're
gonna do that's when Snoke says and
basically you're gonna have to kill your
dad Oh road rage this now that's all in
one convo okay so the only thing that's
dramatically happened to anyone so far
is that thin spent his whole life
training to be a stormtrooper and then
totally [ __ ] changed his mind yeah
when he first saw
all the horrible stuff that to do and he
became a good guy like in it was a huge
experience for him if he is for
sensitive that tremor could have gone
out and everyone would have felt it
mm-hmm no I I'm on the boat basically
all for Finn being for sensitive and
makes so much sense it makes sense that
the wakening was basically a Jedi coming
out of ass if life like net that's
clearly never happened before as far as
stormtroopers go so they're all like
what the hell how did how could this
have happened and you you see it in the
little hologram die like layout of like
been as a boy he was taken they know who
his parents are I'm assuming they might
have that info he does not know his
parents were for sensitive that makes so
much sense that make sense that they
pulled him he just naturally has a
breaking point on his first battle he
knows what's good what's wrong like you
can't you essentially can't brainwash
someone to that extent like if you're
for sensing like he's gonna he's the
snap that makes a lot of sense too
that's like I think we just cracked it
cuz of course he resisted the
brainwashing same way ray resisted the
mind attack from kylo right those are
one and two the same thing yeah so and
here's I think why this has to happen is
because if Finn isn't for sensitive he's
the least skilled or like special star
wars hero ever like he's not like you
have to be a pilot in Star Wars or you
have to be a smuggler if you're not
those then you have to be a politician
he's not he's nothing really he's like
he's a stormtrooper and stormtroopers
aren't good fighters like sure he could
train and become good but right now he
has really nothing going for him unless
he's for sensitive and I think that
would fit because this is about the new
generation of Jedi and just having one
just having ray I think it's not enough
it's not enough I agree with you I think
I think that's going to be basically
episode 8 is like him coming to realize
it and going back they're all gonna go
separate ways just like I mean I'll say
just like Empire Strikes Back you know
like there's going to be some training
people are gonna have to like figure out
their lives and that's what he probably
does is he searches for his family and
finds answers on that yeah that I think
that's huge the force awakens man yeah
it's really grown on me yeah since the
spoiler Cassie's uh josh is what you
have you gone from like an 8 29 anything
I've gone from an 89 it's obviously I've
got mine it picks the raft ours were so
bad that sars unforced that I think they
dug a ditch for them like I think they
like realize they couldn't do much of
this scene yeah and that like they
couldn't cut it because i think it was
it was integral and like they had to
ditch Hans ship somehow right I mean it
wasn't that bad but it wasn't that bad
but it's just like missed opportunity
for that time so that's all I have to
say is like nothing nothing of value
really happened nothing could have any
more JJ Abrams like the rathtar's yeah
and that was the one where he liked but
it in too much yeah but it was uh that's
not yeah that was like the worst scene
but hey whatever it we're good really
cool I wish they were like spoilers and
stuff with x-wings you had nothing to
talk about but there's so sick they were
the x-wings i ja the whole time was just
on the floor I have listened to march of
the resistance on Disney VEVO thousand
times it's just insane but now we're
just good I really hope a star for Speed
wings all right and the other okay bye
guys but I see you guys
you